premier format en plus ou moins immersif
numérique
c'est une méthode innovante de travail
collaboratif en pleine période de
confinement des réunions d'entreprises
en réalité virtuelle spécialisée sur
cette technologie
la start-up minimes antenne sky one
porte à la mise en place cette nouvelle
organisation
on a des contenus c'est ferran de réseau
conseille d'utiliser un casque et même
sur pc on s'est dit allez on va essayer
en quelques jours finalement on a on a
repris notre base de code mais on a
intégré une sorte d'outil qui nous
permet de nous rencontrer en val était
virtuelle dans un bureau virtuel
les collaborateurs sont équipés d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle
chacun chez soi ils sont en immersion
des échanges facilités et quasi
naturelle déjà on est plus fluide
qu'avec du zoo ou du skype parce qu'on
met pas la vidéo on n'en aurait que le
son et des positions d'objets 3d en
termes d'usagé finalement c'est devenu
très naturel c'est ça qui est quand même
surprenant qu on s'est dit on va le
tester on sait pas du tout ce que ça va
donner
et on s'est retrouvé à retrouver mes
mimiques de chacun les tout ce qui est
gestuelle en fait un peu spécifique à
chaque personne voulait retrouver dedans
développé depuis le début du confinement
cette solution est utilisé uniquement
pour l'activité de sky one portal une
phase d'expérimentation avant peut-être
de la commercialiser on ne sait pas
possible on va déjà voir un petit peu
l'intérêt donc on va communiquer un
petit peu sur des réseaux sur ce type d'
usage et si effectivement on sent qu'il
ya une demande
on sera ravi effectivement de proposer
quelque chose qui sont un peu plus
packagées que ce qui est aujourd'hui
pour l'instant à l'état de prototype
spécialisé dans les secteurs du
divertissement de l'événementiel et du
service aux industries
cette start up est impacté par cette
crise plusieurs mesures du gouvernement
ont pu être déclenchées
objectif avoir une visibilité sur le
maintien de la trésorerie d'ici à la fin
de l'année